Aliénor:
Eh, madame !
Auriez-vous vu une pirate traîner dans les
rues, dernièrement?
Ou quelqu'un qui me ressemblait, mais en bourré ?
Passante Vener:
Laissez-moi tranquille, vous êtes folle !
Aliénor:
Mais tout le monde me répond un truc du genre depuis ce matin...
P...M...U... C'est ça, c'est là qu'elle
allait d'après la Prof! Je sens qu'elle
est tout proche, j'en suis sûre!
Aliénor:
Bonjour! Je cherche une pirate.
Serveuse:
Et moi je cherche le sens de la vie.
Vous avez pas plus précis, comme demande? D'habitude les gens demandent à boire
ou un paquet de clopes.
Aliénor:
Euh, j'ai pas soif... Mais j'ai un portrait-automate
si vous voulez!
Serveuse:
C'est une caméra cachée, c'est ça?
Aliénor:
Ok, j'vais me débrouiller sans vous!
Vous êtes pas le seul bar au monde, ok!
Espèce de... Personne négative!
Aliénor:
On lâche rien. ON LÂCHE RIEN!
Passante Royaliste:
Mademoiselle ?
On peut discuter ?
Aliénor:
Vous êtes une pirate?
Passante Royaliste:
Non, mais je représente l'association
« Le retour du roi». Avez-vous déjà rêvé
du retour de la monarchie? L'association
«Le retour du roi» milite pour rétablir
une vraie monarchie de droit divin en France,
afin de venir en aide à des français en perte de repères depuis si longtemps.
Et si ça vous intéresse, n'hésitez pas à aller sur notre site
Pour nous faire un don...
Comme ça on pourra peut-être acheter un trône ou une couronne.
Aliénor:
J'étais comme toi, avant. Ouvre les yeux.
Donc...Bonjour... Il se trouve que je cherche une pirate.
Passant:
Non mais ça m'intéresse pas... Oh, me touche pas !
Aliénor:
C'est important, c'est pour ma vie...
Passant:
Trouve un job ! Pouilleuse.
Aliénor:
Bonjour, monsieur. Vous m'écoutez ? Hein ?
Je cherche une pirate. Je sais pas où elle
est. Je la trouve plus, elle est dans un bar,
je pense, parce qu'elle aime l'alcool...
Aliénor:
Excusez-moi!
Alors voilà, je sais que ça va vous paraître
étrange, mais je cherche une... Femme qui
s'habille en pirate et qui me ressemble, mais
c'est pas moi. Et il est probable que vous
l'ayez croisée ivre dans un bar. Non pas
que je présume que vous passiez vous-même
votre temps ivre dans des bars, mais on sait
jamais... Enfin, vous l'avez vue?
Passant Plinthe:
Bah, oui, ça serait dur de l'oublier... Elle
m'a menacé du supplice de la planche y'a
deux jours.
Aliénor:
Ah, le truc où on vous jette par dessus bord?
Passant Plinthe:
En théorie, oui, mais y'avait pas d'eau,
elle m'a juste frappé avec une plinthe. Mais
elle était bourrée, oui.
Aliénor:
C'est parfait! Où est-ce que je peux la trouver ?
Passant Plinthe:
C'était au Tennessee...
Aliénor:
Merci! Merci merci merci!
LUCRETIA!
Je sais où la pirate se cache.